two days ago and I was okay we are live
with another Google Plus hangout and I'm
excited to have Ricardo salts Gokul with
me he is uh writing a book and it's on
the customer experience and he wanted my
story my advice to to include in the
book and I said instead of me writing
this out let's have a interview so that
other people could benefit from the
experience as well so Ricardo welcome
and dig in let me know what questions
you have no thanks a lot even is a
pleasure to be here with you and thanks
for taking the time to to be with me
here well I would be direct okie because
we don't have too much time and I want
to use your time as better as we can for
my first question for you you have to
date 230,000 followers in the in the
Twitter something like that as I ma'am
if i'm not wrong good correct me but why
you taught that this prosim it approach
that you have today with the people that
you are so clear and honest with the
people while you do why you thought that
this would work for you and why is
working so well what do you think about
that uh well I appreciate that you say
that because I it's something that I
struggle with and and as as I've grown
yeah I never I never intended to be a
huge youtuber or Twitter person it
wasn't my goal um it started as people
would ask me questions you know people
would ask me questions about business I
need help with my startup and I would
write them emails and I would write
pages and pages and pages and just it
took so much time and I was getting so
many emails I said you know I'm going to
do this in video or going to answer them
quickly now on Twitter I so that they
could learn but other people could learn
as well and I'm at the point now with my
audience with YouTube and Twitter and
Facebook where I'm getting so many
comments every day that that it's very
time consuming any comment that you get
on a social network for me is me like if
there's a if there's a Twitter comment
that goes out it's me I wrote that
if it's coming from my end I wrote that
it's not my assistant I have a team I'm
15 people on my team but I'm the guy
actually writing that and I feel uh I
feel if I give that up then it's not
genuine anymore it's not authentic you
know and and it's honestly the best part
of my day like you know what to respond
to people being able to talk to people
like you you know her followers I love
it like that's what gives me energy
that's what keeps me going um and so it
was never really a design strategy I
guess it wasn't I didn't start doing it
because i read it you know on some
website that here's how you have success
with YouTube or Twitter um it just felt
like the right thing to do you know how
people were writing to me and I just
wanted to personally respond and why
what you think that you are a kind of
you have like a magnet to the people
because the people come to you to ask
questions like I found I told you how I
find your funding the Internet in the
time that I was really having a struggle
of myself what I going to do and what
you feel is your key fank that is
attracting the people I'm sorry about
the questions I know that I'm asking
questions that most prob you never
answer them I like it I like the
challenge I like it better than the
questions that I answer the same time
every day um why do people come to me i
think i think a certain demographic come
to me because they see that I've done
some of the things that they want to do
so I've had success in a business I
built it I've I struggled and I talk
about my struggle I don't pretend like
it was easy and I'm the greatest guy
ever and I'm a genius I struggle but I
like that's what I like I almost quit
you know I told my partner I quit I went
through what a lot of people are going
through now with their businesses um and
and I pulled through when i sold my
business for seven figures and i
invested in other companies and so I've
had I guess some degree of success that
people want to emulate and they feel
like I guess I'm being honest now I try
to be honest I try to share what my
honest you're asking me questions I'm
not trying to think of how this is going
to look to my audience of your honor
like that that's you as a and you can
see it's funny because you've seen your
Vitas that you are you there is no no
[ __ ] like people trying to be nice
you you answer how you are I love that
really this is a that's what I'm looking
for on you that's reason we are talking
yeah so like so I mean you answer the
question itself why why are people
attracted to what I'm doing I think I i
try to be authentic to who i am and some
people love that and some people will
hate that some people will see believe
and they'll think I that's stupid you
know you don't need to have passion
around a business you just got to try to
go make money and I'm sure a lot of
people disagree with my views on things
and that's cool and they're fine like
I'm not out there to try to fight them
um I just try to honestly help people
who are having problems with with their
company and give the best advice that I
came from my experience that's it your
idol is Steve Jobs [ __ ] is what you say
always and he's not my idol because his
personality so if I would take him or
you I will take you because I like your
personality you know he was answered say
that people's forgiving someone is
looking at that but he was a kind of bad
guy for some people very mean guy yet
you don't have that and I like this my
idol is actually AP Giannini so if
you're putting me down as who my
favorite entrepreneur is it's AP
Giannini who's the founder of the bank
of america and you may think like a
banker is not somebody who you want to
look up to but look into his story cuz
he did some amazing things he believed
in people he's he was believed he was
the first guy who bet a key bet on Walt
Disney when nobody would bet on Walt
Disney you know I want to make a
full-length cartoon and I want to build
Disneyland like crazy ideas bet on the
Golden Gate Bridge he would when people
were out of money and hard on their luck
he would loan money to people based on a
handshake and a look in there i wish i
could a banker old I'm zelda thought I
trust you yeah you're gonna pay me back
the money can you imagine a banker doing
it now so um yeah so that's I mean he's
my number one entrepreneur but I do
admire Steve Jobs a lot and I think and
it's
Steve Jobs is very polarizing person
some people love them some people hate
them I think what you can do is take
elements that you like from those people
and apply them to your life that's what
I'm doing to you that's that's the way
because otherwise you never give the guy
and he is very important because he he
broke the experience that that's a
incepted with the iphone and ipod etc he
started the mindset of experience and
that's the important part what we broke
for us my second question for you like
you have evolved during the last I think
year and a half you are evolving all the
time but in your customer experience if
you and today in the past I remember as
I mentioned to you in private I went
your side and was kind of well was
difficult to find something and today is
so easy because you organized it that in
a nice way so I understand that you are
kind of evolving also in your mindset of
customer experience what what leads you
to that and how how do you realize it
that something was to complicate it and
you made that easy right now um great
you know you make me think here ah sorry
sorry I apologize making people think
it's good it's a good quality um I had a
big change in my business sinks actually
talking with steve jobs after I watched
the jobs movie I don't know if you've
seen the jobs food with Ashton Kutcher
and it's a decently um and and I came
out of that you know I guess before that
I watched a whole string of bad movies
or movies it didn't move me and there
are a number of movies that I find that
you know when you watch a movie or a
video or you hear somebody speak you get
you get that feeling of excitement that
energy that gives you the confidence to
break out of your comfort zone and
believe in your bold idea and want to go
do it you know even when everything and
everybody else around is telling you not
to uh we don't constantly live like that
for most people and and when we get
injected with those things
it uh it gives us encouragement to go
and follow our dreams and so you know I
got a little boost watching the jobs
movie and it made me realize that after
watching those other movies that they
weren't inspiring me and I I took a look
on my website i found that it wasn't it
wasn't as inspiring as it could be and
and that feeling that is kind of
uplifting believe is getting people to
want to take action is now something
that I wanted to lead with and so I
wanted people to get the feeling first
before they engage with whatever article
product whatever it was that was listed
on the website and so I really think
that this appearance now is much easier
much and when you get there you see
right way if your video there is really
nice I think you did you use it somehow
a user experience experts or you did if
your team and that's all uh you know
that's probably a blind spot for me I
could probably do that better there were
the website is a reflection of me and my
current state of mind very often so you
know I wanted to so after that movie you
know I came out and say i want i want
the top to be a better experience for
the customers for our audience and and
it evolved that it wasn't what you see
now it started off as just pictures it
might be a picture of Steve Jobs or
jay-z or Bill Gates or you know Donald
Trump some entrepreneur with a quote
that was inspiring and then we changed
it to have some audio it was a speech
that somebody was giving and now it's
evolved to be videos and and I pick
those videos at the top I picked them
all those are all videos that inspire me
so it's selfish but you know I want to
go to my own website and be inspired and
so I thought that's a nice nice way to
do to do the things I really like that i
like it also very much your video in
malaysia that was great if it was in the
morning until late evening yeah so for
people you know me may not have seen
that I went to Malaysia and
was I had breakfast with a woman who was
a victim of bullying and and she came up
and told her story and and she she was
it wasn't great like she wasn't a good
public speaker she didn't get you didn't
do a good job telling her story so she
was on just before me and I used the
first part of my presentation to forget
about my presentation and talk about her
and what she had been through when and
then I had everybody come up and take a
picture with her and I gave everybody a
prize who would take a picture with her
with peace and hashtag and put it on
Twitter and um really gave her
confidence and changed her life and very
moving like she was crying half the
audience was crying and just a really
moving maybe one of my favorite
presentations that I've given and it
wasn't about me it was about helping
this woman as well this was really cool
really oh I love your actions you you
you are a special you're not like
everyone in the web and those three key
guys I really like this I wish it was
actually recorded like I wish I they
were supposed to record that session but
they didn't so there's no video of it so
I just went back there as partners up
there's a part of your speech there only
yeah what I went to my I spoke three
times in Malaysia and so three of the
other two were but the one with the
woman the bullying one wasn't so I just
went back to my hotel room and I
recorded something quick and I cry a
little bit on the camera and so it was
yeah who is moving how is it that was a
special that's a special day yeah like
of the video let me ask you another
question how are you measuring for
example companies like I'm working
samsung brand and dogs very large
companies so they managed a the customer
experience in different ways because
like you are not samsung gasps you are
even so for sure you measure it another
way how you are measuring your success
how are you measuring online first in
using a using a business intelligence
analytics and how you are measuring also
in your daily life you know some
companies mejor de de su cells with roi
but I don't think that you are
during roi because you have different
things you have different approach there
so we're trying to bring inspiration for
the people as you have your believers I
am one of them so how you are measuring
this kind of success like ah yeah it's a
great question I think sorry about the
question I know that I'm exposing you
here that's like I'm good expose away
I'm liking it um I think that a lot of
companies and a lot of people make the
mistake of just looking at numbers as
I'm trying to try to quantify success
and as a result not really having an
impact and what I think what's really
important is to make the big decisions
with your heart and the small decisions
with your head so you should be making
something you know the website is a
reflection of me I want to be proud of
it first and foremost like I want to go
to the website and be excited I want to
make videos that are important oughta
make videos that help change people's
lives and and the numbers come second
right so I would make a video that would
really if I felt it would really help
one person's life I would make that
video and I don't care about the views
of the comments on it because I feel
like that was an important video to make
I'm taking a stand and I think that's
why people you asked before why are
people drawn to me and why people drawn
to people like me I guess I'm passionate
what I do right and you have to care
about what you do and so you make your
big decisions with your heart even when
it doesn't make sense quantitatively you
know for me to leave a potential
opportunity when I was in university to
take a six-figure job flying around the
world doing my dream job to do a art up
business we're making three hundred
dollars a month and I don't know how I'm
going to survive doesn't make any sense
it's not logical quant you look at the
numbers it's an easy easy decision why
would you do this startup where you're
going to go broke but but it didn't feel
right and so I did the business and I
ended up making way more than I
at that job and so the numbers can lie
and I think they're important but the
big decisions you need to make with your
heart so I do I measure it's not like I
don't do any quantifying I don't do any
tracking I measure my success on YouTube
success I mean in terms of views on a
video comments on the video new
subscribers for the month and I'll play
with the formatting so this is this
maybe this is an example that might help
help this kind of explain the point I
irie selected my youtube channel so
you've seen my video so that you know
this might help you I looked at the
different kinds of videos i was doing so
some of them would be I had a one-minute
Monday where I do a message in under two
minutes every monday i found that those
were massively underperforming my
regular Q&A so if i mention a question
from somebody that video will do better
in terms of numbers and subscribers and
comments than my 1-minute monday series
so as a result of that data i cut out
the one minute monday series so ongoing
i think there's one more coming next
week and that's that's the end at least
for now the one minute monday series
unless people freak out and they miss
and they want it back but you know i am
not personally attached so much to the
one minute monday right it's a great
idea but i don't feel like i'm going to
do this regardless because I feel it's
important to do but there are other
videos that I would do that for if I
feel like I can have an impact and help
somebody I don't care about the metrics
I'm going to do it because it's
important and you know my decision to be
on YouTube in the first place was
because I want to help people through
video I learn visually and so that you
know the numbers may have said hey go to
Facebook is better go to Twitter it's
better go to LinkedIn it's better yeah
but I feel like in my heart I'm gonna
have more more success more fun add more
value by being on YouTube and so I will
make the little decisions like cutting
one minute monday is a little decision
and it's easy to make that based on data
but the content that I focus on what I'm
talking about is coming from the heart
whether it's a one-minute monday or I'm
answering somebody
question I'm passionate about it I feel
it's the right thing to do I don't make
videos just because I'm trying to this
is how companies do it okay this is why
it's backwards companies will say okay
we want a video that's going to get them
get us a million views or 50,000 views
or whatever it is and so they try to
reverse-engineer what makes a successful
50,000 view video and then they they
piece it together but there is never any
heart in it they're just trying to get
that number but that number is
meaningless and they'll never get there
because they're missing the heart the
most important ingredient in the video
in Malaysia is up on a was watching the
pain of people who were talking about
how to make a video go viral and they're
talking all the numbers and metrics and
none of them had actually had a video go
viral and so good luck can't just
reverse engineer it ranked it starts
with a passion to want to help somebody
or to want to change the world somehow
you know something that comes from here
that's unquantifiable big decisions with
the heart and then the smaller ones with
your head what what you're saying what i
get from what you're saying I think
heart is important passion is important
but align it with a great content and
that's what I think you have yes because
if you was telling I so many people that
have great videos very engaging views
even more than yours as many people have
all the kind of crazy videos but they
don't have the great content & great
content is that counts and honesty
honesty is the game here a genuine t
honesty and great content I think you
have that in a top level so my kudos for
you now another question that I'd like
to know from you you have a great
community I don't know how many people
you have in your commutative really
following in and always engage with you
I'm seeing you all the times you are in
my mail so I'm always checking or stuff
out but I am assuming that not everybody
sees in that way because I am I kind of
I like the things that you say and
you're my inspiration not a believer but
I inspirational so my question for you
is the following how are you using your
community
improve your products and services
because you have for example let's take
these lights I'm assuming that you
brought you bilder slides from requests
like the people and didn't ask you a
beauty slide that you tell me what I
have to know what I'm going to be my
university for example just a sample but
was the people as asking 1,000,000 times
it's the same thing and you got kind of
tired to answer the same question when
we don't I'm so you did his lights and
that's a great solution as for you and
for the people so how is your process of
creating the experience of your products
and services online yeah another great
question I think everything everything
that I do is either reflection of my
audience and in a question problem that
they're going through or just something
that I feel inspired or move by and I
want to share I try to think back to me
yeah well let me want your second I'm
sorry so that means that you are
engaging with them you are reading what
they are saying and then you are free oh
I have to talk about that because those
guys want to know about that that's the
way you are you are acting in your like
slides and the material that you are
making a lot I put a adding online how
is the process that that's the question
how you are engaging yeah so on that
side if it's not something that comes
from me that like I feel this is an
important message but it's coming from
the audience I I can only answer so much
in a video right if I'm making a five
minute video about how to find your
passion I can only you know I can only
answer so much so I video is only part
of the solution and if I get asked
something enough and there's there's a
lot of demand for and then I'm getting
asked in a lot of different ways i can
keep making videos but it's it's more to
the product so you're talking about the
zucca guides I'm assuming is to take
people deeper so if you really want to
find your passion to start your business
or if you really want to find your first
customer if you really want to find how
to make alliance partners that I've
created guides and that's more you know
imagine me sitting down next
to you on the couch for half an hour
we're talking about your business so the
videos even the Twitter and the emails
are our quick hits you know and
sometimes it's all people need sometimes
they just need that quick little bit of
advice and they're they're moving on and
for people who want to dive deeper into
it I've got enough questions I got
enough response is I got enough people
asking me the same thing in different
ways that i made the more in depth
guides it could be the product guide it
could be a twitter chat i do once a
month twitter chat with dell and we have
different topics and those topics are
chosen by what are people asking me
about right so instead of now just
having a video response hey you have me
for an hour on twitter let's chat you
have a question about this let's talk
about it and so we pick the topics based
on what people are asking me yeah I
don't want to be unwise but you told me
that we have half hour do you have some
more minutes to ask more short three
questions uh yeah we got this I don't
have anything immediately after so we
can go over a little bit yeah so I can
answer all the questions that's great
thank you very much i will give example
now let me know what you think about for
example SCP if you take a sip in the
market and oracle that they are
competitors the difference between both
companies that are huge the largest
application companies in the world is
none there's no difference the only
difference that exists there is almost
believed but it stressed I you buy from
me one project worth 1 million dollars
on one bid on doors whatever it is
depending of how we trust me because
both compress doesn't have a huge
difference in the process and the
features how do you see the trust factor
playing today in the business that's the
important because your your your
business is all about trust I'm not
going to come to you for example I am
older than you yes you have 75 I have 99
so I'm not going to come to you if I
don't trust you yes I most probably i
have different experience than you you
have another kind of experience and many
other people
so you have some factors that make the
people trust you how you define
tourister how you you you sit in parts
of trusted in the business and
especially in your business taking the
example that I told you the Oracle NSA p
kind of example that there are both the
same but the wing the winner will be
always who established rest of the
clients what do you think about that ah
yeah so I have a theory about selling
and I think the difference is the core
and so if you look at how most companies
start and build up to become you know
ASAP Oracle they'll usually start
selling their their features right I'm a
saw my features we can offer you this
this speed modem or you know that
whatever the individual features are the
the certain air soul on a shoe and then
you you work up the benefits and this is
for small business to you start
everybody starts as the technician
cluttered you work the benefits benefits
is you know i'm not i'm not selling the
air souls on the shoe i'm selling the
faster running experience right and so
the big companies do this and then
somewhere along the lines is an
entreprenuer that you stop selling
features you start selling benefits may
be sought in a video or book but then
the next step up which very few people
do is core selling and core selling is
figuring out what you staying for as a
business and getting people on board
with your mission and that's what
creates massive advocates fanatics you
look at the loyalty towards a company
like Apple they would buy any product
because it's Apple because they know
that Apple represents a certain thing
and that will never has to compare
themselves to anybody else because they
stand for something and so what's the
difference between SI p and Oracle I
don't know like what are they stand for
I don't know the question is not about
about about that questions about trust
how much should import for example you
establish trust with me if I even didn't
know you I for me was a guy enough video
okay but I so well this guy knows what
he's talking about in is not a [ __ ]
guy
and I think we've maybe not only me but
1 million people that are following you
have the same feeling because the people
are not going to follow if they think
that you are a guy that doesn't know
what you are talking about so the
question is how do you see the trust
playing today in the business not just
in our businesses in overall business
because usually you buy from someone
that you trust what's or totes about the
trust factor today in the business
because if you think you have so many
technology today evolving yes and
everything is depending of why you buy
Apple because I trust Apple because I
know that they are they doing a great
experience they are doing great products
at the top quality and I like them and I
have a story with them as I found in
love Steve Jobs like you did you know so
those those aspects are are the
important ones so I would like to hear
from you your thoughts about your assets
to build trust of the people how have we
did that do not tend to come beautiful
guy there in the videos and started to
say something there was a trigger here
because other people that are online
that are digital interpreters as you are
today as you was not before but you have
something that other people doesn't have
and and that's what I saw on you and as
soon as I started to follow you so
that's my question for you about stress
how you I am sure that not a part of a
strategy you know a marketing strategy
what is you so I want to understand how
you you build that trick of dressed with
people i don't know if i call it a chick
but it's not a trick a trick is a bad
word it's not a trick is your tatting I
don't know is you yes you inspire trust
now again it comes from me it comes to
the core right like I stand for
something right I believe in
entrepreneurs if you if you want to be
an entrepreneur or if you are an
entrepreneur you're probably going to
like a lot of what I have to say you're
going to be inspired by the channel
you're going to want to watch and tune
in not not because I'm telling you not
because I'm saying I'm the greatest
thing ever but because you like what I
stand for and you staying for the same
thing if you're not an entrepreneur or
you don't want to become one you're not
going
to get a lot of value from my channel
like big companies look at me and they
don't get it they don't want me to come
speak to their employees because I'm
going to tell everybody to go start
their own business which they don't want
so but that's fine like i have a clearer
segmentation my audience loves me they
know who i am and everybody else that
they have their own opinions and that's
fine but it's coming down to for me to
have trust in that community from my
community of entrepreneurs it's they
know that I stand for something
important and I'm authentic in that
right and so I stand up for
entrepreneurs and I stand up for what I
believe is is right for them and I try
to share my advice in as honest and
authentic away as possible so I think
for companies they need to figure out
what they stand for you want you want to
have trust with your customers what do
you stand for what is your business all
about because I I just see a logo and so
if you come out that there's here's an
example is a company called the honest
company which recently started they sell
diapers and they sell beauty and bath
products 0 in 23 years they became worth
a billion dollars and everything is
around honest so you know they want to
treat their employees honestly they want
to treat their their their customers
honestly they're creating honest product
so if you're you're you're having a
diaper put it on your child it doesn't
have chemicals in it everything is about
honest for them this is a name of their
business and so if you go and you buy
something from that company you know
everything has been made honestly and
they're trying to have an honest
positive impact in the world some people
see that and they say on a stupid honest
come on there's no room for honesty in
business it's just about making money
whatever and that's cool like that's not
there's lots of people who believe that
and those guys are not going to be fans
of the honest company on the other side
there are people who love that message
and really believe in it and and they
built a loyal honest you know following
fanatic following so that whenever they
release they don't have to talk about
the the features of it and the benefits
of it first because they've already
built up
a culture of trust through their message
of honesty and so I think every business
needs to do that you build trust by
having a powerful message that you stand
for something important and most
companies don't you know most companies
have these values these here are 10
values that we stand for and I bet if
you go to ask their employees what their
10 values are ninety-nine percent of
them couldn't list all 10 of them and so
it means the company doesn't stand for
anything right and so you know pick the
one thing that you staying for and and
make it make it powerful and if you're
authentically behind that then you will
inspire the trust of people to come and
want to buy your products and be
followers of your business how do you
see the quality of content impacting the
experience today because I see so many
like a give example you have great
content for sure you are that I think is
the the key success factor the leverage
do for your success otherwise if you are
selling [ __ ] I show people a a few
years ago I work it in a company that I
needed to know how to traffic works not
not drugs i mean a trafficking
interested so my intention here was a
and i need to learn but I did know where
so i start to to dig in internet I found
many people that will explain them this
is about traffic Cal can find out all of
them needs looks like tricky gurus and
then I found a guy that was really
honest and I really like it the content
how he were explaining very very nicely
how do you think the content factor is
playing today in the world and what you
advise for people and this is a special
thing that I have in my book that's not
going to be connected exactly if your
business case but I want to hear what
you think about that I'm sorry to that
something totally else that's okay I
think it depends on if you're playing
the long game with a short game I think
if you are just playing the short game
Oh is always I think always longitude
BTW ok that's a in customer experience
that you cannot win today is not that I
going to sell you that in one game my
idea is to sell you dissed and my
upgrade and my upgrade
I want you to have something that is
invisible when you are doing like that
your hands yeah well okay with that
that's your view but that's not the view
of a lot of people that's correct and so
that's reflective in the experience
because somebody who just cares about
getting my money right now is going to
hard sell me right they know they know
I'm never going to come back to their
website this is the only chance they
have this al me so they're going to put
all these pop-ups and like are you sure
you want to leave are you sure you want
to cancel cancer right like they know
I'm never coming back and so they're
trying to bombard me and and and it
works like if that didn't work people
wouldn't do it so that does work but
it's a very short term strategy and
usually those products suck right and
that's why you're never coming back and
they know it so they're just trying to
rip you off it and you can make money uh
you can make money scamming people it
happens all the time it's just not a way
that I choose to do business I really
value the people armed who are following
me uh you know as we as we're doing this
video we've got people chatting shout
out two chefs TV and an ED who are loyal
youtubers and and they're there watching
and chatting and asking questions and um
you know you gotta you gotta do it
because you want to build you gotta care
about your customers right if you care
about your customers and your focus on
the long-term then when somebody you
know I'm not selling anything in my
first video right I make tons of stuff
told if you're free we're doing this
interview I'm sure it's my audience
totally for free because I love doing it
and because they care about
entrepreneurs and that's going to
attract people who like that message and
eventually they they may get on my
newsletter they may buy a product that
I'm selling to me join something that's
paid that I have and that's cool and if
they don't that's cool too you know like
as long as you're being respectful as
long as you're out there trying to have
an impact and change the world like I
want to help you regardless of if you're
buying something from me or not and so I
think it's just a mindset of the the
company if you're thinking short-term
you're thinking money right now in the
bank then you're doing the scammy things
you're doing that you're never coming
back to my site it's a terrible customer
experience
where if you care about the long-term
then you invest in those things and it's
really caring about your customers and
in thinking about you know what they
want to accomplish and trying to be a
part of their success perfect and I have
our last question for you is about how
do where you are going where you see
you're in like in three years from now
five years from now what to re-envision
for for the even garmi oh uh Brent uh
I'm not that smart uh I mean my big goal
is to help a billion entrepreneurs my
the thing that it's it's a number you
know that what really motivates me is
waking up every day and doing something
to help business owners somehow i love
how I love helping people just my skill
set you know if I can't help somebody
understand German you know I don't speak
German that's not my calling I can't
help them so I can help entrepreneurs
I'm good at it so I want to do that and
I think as I grow more and more I'm I
want to help people who want to have a
positive impact and that's where I'm
spending more of my time and that's not
most people you know a lot of
entrepreneur to business because they're
trying to pay off their dads they trying
to you know make a lot of money and I
usually I meet them you know I'll get
them some advice and help but it's not
somebody who I get really connected to
wear more and more I want to help the
people who really want to have a
positive impact on the world and I want
to be able to use whatever knowledge
resources ideas I have to help them go
out and make a huge impact my business
is and I think always will be of a
reflection of me and what i'm doing and
what i'm thinking so it started off
being my website and i was posting
content and i expanded the social media
and started on linkedin then what the
facebook and then went to Twitter and
now i'm on youtube and let me change you
know the five years there may be a brand
new thing that comes out that is amazing
and and that's where i'm going to be you
know i don't know
um but but it's always going to be
around helping entrepreneurs and in
trying to have a major impact wherever
that is so one thing that I i like very
much and I when you when I first
actually come to your site that I pray
attention is that if you had more
languages for example if you have like
brazil israel and here in europe and
asia you would help their billion people
now that video don't have yet we are in
seven but you would help much more if
you have more language but it's very
difficult to do content in other
languages but brazil specific brazil i
was born in brazil but I'm I'm Germany's
and Israeli and I when I show your stuff
your material I said wow this guy have
to have this is material in Portuguese
because that you sell medals in Brazil
you sell me those because that's a great
market for you for what you are doing
because the people are really minded in
interpreter ship right now is a is a
great china is a great place and not
give you ideas just some totes that I
have during the my experiences with you
coming to your site let me tell you what
I going to do now I'd like to do I want
to comment on that quick I want to
comment on that three this is a classic
um think with your heart versus think
with your head and if my only goal was
here when I have a billion entrepreneurs
then let me translate everything I have
in the Chinese or you know get somebody
to be Evan Carmichael China and and say
what I'm saying in Chinese uh and I
would get to my number a lot faster but
for me I i love entrepreneurs wherever
the foam and I answer questions from
people around the world and you're you
know I mean I'm in Toronto you're in
Germany we're talking uh I feel like I
only speak English you know I speak a
little Italian this week a little bit
French that's where my passion is and
and for me too I don't think that it
comes across well enough having chinese
subtitles over what I'm
pain versus me being able to speak
Chinese fluently and really deliver my
message and so that's that's a hard
decision like I want everything that I
make to be awesome and I'm proud of it
and it's really going to move people and
I don't I'll do things so that that may
be the detriment of my business right I
could be way bigger than I am right now
maybe by being in China and Europe and
Brazil and have with everything
multilingual and maybe I'll find the
right partner who can explode this thing
for me but it's not something that I'm
that I'm actively pursuing because for
me it's just it's too much of a hey this
is a logical thing to do but not
something I'm passionate about doing and
so I've always been the passion guy
first and and maybe that's to my own
detriment you know maybe maybe I'm a
stupid or doing that I don't fit either
I didn't I didn't say that if intention
of criticize or not I just told you that
there are many opportunities that you
are not exploiting because barriers but
I think you do you do really well if you
was trying that because you have this
you have something to other people I'm
sorry to repeat that look you have
something that other people doesn't okay
yeah and that's the Democrats for a lot
of entrepreneurs like this can be a lot
of opportunities people say I should be
on Instagram people say I should be
doing more on linkedin you know you got
to evaluate the opportunities not just
on the numbers but again where you feel
in your heart is the best thing for you
to do I grew do all right so let me tell
you what I'm going to do now I going to
prepare the business case I just want to
ask you something can you send me a kind
of your background because I didn't
found in our website the kind of a media
background those kinds of things if you
go to Evan chemical calm / about about
oh yeah why you say that before and
lowercase a it'll be there all right and
I going to write business case and send
you to your approval because everybody
have to approve their own business case
okay you cannot publish a book without
approvals otherwise because it's like
that you know orico is in my book and us
and the sales force
and I have so many problems with them
because they asked me to change like
mine or words you know like because they
don't like that so I have to change this
but that's life yes do it looks like
yeah I'm pretty flexible in general on
that but you know for people watching
where I where is your book gonna be how
can they find out more information about
you well Ricardo so let's go go am I
have my website I send you I think in
the in the mail and I have also my
linkedin but right now I hate
structuring my website to the book so we
are preparing that right now the book
would be lunch it most probably in July
or August we are going to lunch in Nam
in north america first and then we are
going to lunch in europe and UK and then
we're going to lunch everywhere in the
world as we go so why i am doing that
now is because we have to lunch before
the frankfurt fear that is the global
fear of books if you lunch before that
you can be global and you can lunch ever
endured if you don't do that you have to
wait for the next year so that's the
reason I'm like you're hurrying and
interviewing everyone right now in doing
every feast and that's the reason I say
that those made us because I told boy I
have to let him in my book because your
case I knew that you are going to come
to my book that was my intention to
invite you since the beginning when I
started to build up the book and then I
was so busy working and also write in
the book that I totally forgot you know
and I said well yeah and you are is my
strategic plan of my book I have
excelled that is the who have to be my
book so I have to invite many people and
you was one of the last but I said well
I have to talk of him and then they
start to approach as I hey can you can
you answer can you answer and then
finally we are here and and I'm really
thankful that you accepted there that's
really great if you have any more
questions where is that ty was at your
last one I had other questions but wait
a circle some of them you answer so I
don't need that I just wanted to get
your mindsets that's more important for
me
one question I am a high technology guy
okay and in my book we are going to talk
a lot about communities because I think
the community like Apple they can
understand what you need but the trees
day they have a very quiet marketing
strong team that are working all the
time you first we just don't know that
all right that's the reason they can
read your minds and you buy the next
product and the next product then that's
where they do it now how do you see
communities working for the benefit of
the users or the buyers services and I
asked you that before any other way now
ask you about apple and about I'm am
bill I'm a big believer that communities
is the future of the products and
services what do you think about that
because you can mold like I have this
bottle for you and then you tell me I
want the same bottle in like that i
don't know like that you know this is
imagine that this is a bottle i put a
like a drop of water here and that's
inflates something like that what do you
think about that about communities
influence in the world right now because
today always about your tribe yes if you
have a tribe of followers you can be
successful if you don't you cannot be
successful yeah I'm there you know
there's two schools of thought I i don't
know if i have a hard opinion on it um
but you leave the one if you want your
product or service to be successful you
need to get you need to get people to
love it and use it right you're going to
make money by providing value the more
value you provide the more money you're
going to make so to get your customer
feedback and experience is going to help
you build a better product and it's
never been easier to to get that
feedback right the technology has made
it so easy for us to get feedback from
people and even the fun completely new
ideas with with web sites like
Kickstarter that it's only going to
become easier and easier and easier and
easier to do that
on top of that the one cabinet i would
say is you know advice from akio morita
who is a founder of Sony sometimes you
need to have the visionary leader to
know what's possible you know sometimes
your community can help you have minor
tweaks and changes and say do I want
this bottle and purple or blue or
smaller or bigger but they can't imagine
a bottle on wheels that can fly to the
moon or something right like if you have
some bigger vision of what you want to
accomplish I then that that can still
come from you and you can have your
community refine it and tune it and make
it better so i think the the initial
idea should come from you and not just
listening to customers and not having a
vision right you gotta I guess I do have
a strong I started by saying I didn't
have a strong opinion but I have a
strong opinion I think you need to have
that vision right you need to know where
you're going with the business this is
the same thing like big big decisions
with your heart the big decision with
your heart is here's where I'm going
here's what I want to try to accomplish
is what I want to build and put out
there in the world and then the the
small decisions is is the the numbers
the data the talking to customers
getting their feedback making it better
you know I'm okay to switch from YouTube
to yak yak or you know some some others
like thing I've never even heard of
because as for my audience is going to
be now I'm okay to switch to that
because that's a little decision but I'm
still going to be helping entrepreneurs
some way and so I think companies who
are trying to design a new you know if
you're designing a book right you're
writing this book the vision for the
book should be based on what you believe
right you're trying to you have strong
opinions on customer experience so
you're writing this book on customer
experience and the direction of the book
might change a little bit as you talk to
me as you talk to other people they go
there's a new way that I didn't think of
before talking to these people open up
my mind and now this other angles and so
you add that in but but you don't want
the community then building the entire
book like you need
have this vision for very you have to do
I value you are the driver and I agree
with you that's a great actually great
what you said because it's really like
that i have to i am driving but i'm not
i'm taking I taking clients like people
that give me opinions and sometimes I
exactly what you said happened I was
when I started the book was one thing
right now after we hear so many people I
have totally different opinion is going
to be something totally different one
last question for you we are doing in
the book we are going to have
argumentative reality in your business
case we sort say that in public your
business case we can put a video of you
okay talking about your experience I
will tell you later what we can talk
about everybody mail that but are you
comfortable with that to record a video
for the book that will be ever there
forever you know what is augmented
reality ah a relative morality is the
thing that you you take your phone you
make a download of application for every
then let's imagine i have heerd this
bottle then I come here and I put my
phone in direction in the in this stock
here of veto okay okay then I see
instead of seeing that I see your video
and then you are there so your business
case will be here then we'll be a sign
over your business case to people who do
like that pic if the application if they
download there is the part i doing that
and then they see your video and that to
happen in your shaft is because i have
some contributors i'm writing sixty
seventy percent of the book but in parts
of them weaker I talk some contributors
so I want everybody that especially
companies and people that are
participating like yourself if possible
that you record later video and then we
can have a video from you talking about
your business case HP much help I'm
happy to help I mean tell me the details
I'm happy to make a video as long as I
have the technology to do and happy to
help yeah yeah that's a normal video you
have great video so talk about
I have a couple questions from people
who are watching live stream that I want
to I want to answer uh if you're okay
with that sure sure I I don't you know I
don't see people here so I told that
there is no people oh no you got to be
on the YouTube page not on the google
plans so kallik son is asking what does
customer experience mean to you um what
does customer experience before meal for
you to me what does customer experience
mean to me but I mean you can answer to
all these questions that I'm not used to
answering I can I can assure you answer
well I think okay so customer experience
imagine today the companies as we spoke
before as well as we discuss it the
company's differentiation if you take
through competitors are where is mobius
everybody's trying to do the best in the
majority of the case that there are
exceptions a lot of receptions actually
but what differentiate you from your
competitor is the experience how we
engage how you keep your clients how
engage them in social media personally
yes so what customer experiences today
is the definition of your logic tivity
because if you don't provide a great
experience for your client a great
experience like I bought this boat oh
and then i have a problem of the boat i
didn't like it the bottle come broke and
just a damp example for example for you
so then i can i go to the supermarket
and I trying to change the bottle and
they say no you already bought you did
you did open even so I don't want to
change you so they are lost in a client
and they are not seeing my life my life
value for day business so that's a big
mistake so the experience is how I
engage how I give you value can be the
digital can be face-to-face can be a
product can be a services but that's
about what is the experience in the life
cycle if I have to put that in if you
had more time as I could explain you in
a long perspective all the details about
profit customer experience but in the
short
in a short explanation the experience is
the longitude video that you want to
give for your company how we engage how
you delivery is five main elements the
one is the sales cycle the second is the
is the delivery cycle the third is the
maintenance cycle for anything yes and
align it with the quality of your
services and products because even if I
have a great experience talking with you
and my project is bad or myself sees bad
you're not going to stay with me or not
going to be my fun you're not going to
be my advocate later so it's very
important to controi these five things
together and then provide a great
experience and that's how you treat your
client your patience to do a mistake you
recognize the mistake are many aspects
here I hope I answer your question
unfortunately I cannot see your comments
but I'm trying just to explain yeah so I
mean Ricardo said a lot there a lot of
great stuff I would just I would just
add care I mean customer experience to
me is care I care that's great that's
great we should care and and then that
translates in everything into your
website into your sales process into all
of the specifics that Ricardo mentioned
the five steps care right like you have
to actually care about your customers if
you do you worry about providing a great
customer experience you know the other
question maybe last question cuz I gotta
wear his short short short short uh ed
was we got DIY engineer said very very
well said Ricardo so you got some fans
there ed said some of my values and
beliefs are contradicting my business
idea but I feel sinister following this
dream yeah that's an easy one if your
values and your beliefs are
contradicting your business idea don't
do it you can't do business that you
don't feel is in line with your values
it should be the opposite right you
gotta start with your values and then
bring that to your business so I don't
know what your business ideas but that
isn't easy that's that's that's making
decision with your head instead of your
heart right that that's the I'm trying
to make money quickly doing something
that I don't
you know I don't feel good about and
that's never took never way to make a
successful business long term so i would
say Eddie as a tough love as this is
your right to feel sinister about it
stop doing it and do something that you
feel you can actually contribute to the
world with and is in mind with your
beliefs yeah and believe this do the
main thing here believe passion else
with you if you how we can be successful
something that you don't believe that
you don't have passion for is impossible
practically unless you know you want to
be unhappy so I advise you to do what
even as yourself because that's the
what's on your shirt Eddie what's on the
shirt all right wing it that's anyway I
gotta run a you know Ricardo thank you
so much for the questions good luck with
the book and keep me posted and
everybody watching I appreciate the love
and comments and this isn't possible at
all without your your love and support
so i will keep track of what Ricardo's
up to thank you guys for joining in and
I'll see you soon and all right thank
you very much even for your time
appreciate it take care you too thanks
nice to meet you bye bye